all women deserve to feel beautiful i
truly believe that it makes you
even more of an awesome person when you
can find beauty within others
less is best and that's kind of my
attitude when i'm at home my family and
they're loving me i feel beautiful
it's moments like that that really make
me feel good about myself is feeling
that love
that's really where beauty comes from
from the inside how you feel about
yourself versus how you're seen
[Music]
hello i'm alicia johnson and i'm so
excited that you're joining us for a raw
and open conversation about how black
beauty is represented in 2021
we're going to take a look at where we
are the work that still needs to be done
and the people who are moving us forward
speaking of those people i am joined by
tasha lako brown
a chanel makeup artist who boasts
celebrity clients like tracee ellis ross
and michael b
jordan darian harvin a reporter who
covers beauty at the intersection of
politics and pop
culture and tash nubei a zimbabwean born
body positive supermodel
ladies thank you so much for joining me
i've been waiting for a minute to have
this conversation with each and every
one of you
when you think of black beauty in 2021
how would you describe it boundless
oh i like that boundless
yes boundless i feel like with
the connectivity that social media
brings
where you can connect directly with the
culture and
you can take it all over the globe and
you're getting to see
everyone's personal connection to their
art to their beauty to their face
i feel like it's boundless i feel like
i'm seeing in real time
things that are amazing in uganda i'm
seeing nigerian
hair shows in real time i'm seeing
london street culture
in real time so i feel like black beauty
is boundless in 2021
barian are you going to have an answer
as poetic as sasha
because that was good how would you
describe that
no good yeah i would describe
black beauty in 2021 as black women
doing
whatever they want with their beauty and
it is so amazing and exciting to see
to witness and to be a part of that i
would say
it's barrier breaking what are some of
the trends that started in the black
community
that you're excited about that stands
out to you the most when you get online
or when you see them out and about
i know there's so many trends that have
been started by black people and we just
don't get the same recognition which is
very frustrating
i'd also say the nails love that that's
definitely
an aesthetic that is i think it's just a
trend that's kind of like
gone all around the world because even
in australia that's also a trend
um and i think just
just everything i think every like black
women really start everything i can't
lie like i think that
we are the original transporters i
wanted to add to that like nail art is
amazing it's like
you can get millions and billions of
views name plates are amazing the big
hoop earrings are amazing
but i think the reason why i'm so in
love with social media
is because as black women we're used to
being innovators and trendsetters
and then we see our culture regurgitated
back to us
and sold to us at a higher price like
the little bonnet thing like my bonnet
cost
two dollars did you really just put a
little sparkly pin on it and try to sell
it back to me for
eight dollars so wait wait wait where
did you see that
oh my gosh is that a surreal experience
a real
thing so it's a very surreal experience
to see your culture regurgitated back at
you and when it's regurgitated back at
you
suddenly now it's fashionable and it's
cool but for me
it was cool when it was just cool when i
saw it in the street
that is why social media is so amazing
to me because you cannot
you can know it's no longer just simply
it's no longer easy to strip
our creative credit away from us let's
talk about some of the celebrities who
have been accused of black fishing
and cultural appropriation so black
fishing is when a non-black person
pretends to be black on their social
media
by culturally appropriating black
features in an attempt to gain
followers and attention i didn't even
know there was a word in 2018
kim kardashian faced backlash online
after she wore
cornrows to the mtv movie and tv awards
when you see things like that does it
stir any negative emotion inside of you
or do you look at it like
it's a positive thing that these people
see something that they like from my
culture
and they want to emulate it how do you
view it i think that it's not that my
feelings on it have changed but my
understanding of how
it happened has evolved and has changed
as i
have started to get older myself because
of my experience as a reporter
so me and we had a conversation at the
beginning of this just about um what
we're excited about
and so i think that i do this balance of
acknowledging and understanding
the harm that culture that cultural
appropriation has caused on the i think
image or the kind of the self-confidence
of black women and i think black people
but i'm also really trying to focus on
um what we have made happen for
ourselves in this space
um despite the lack of recognition and
despite
the lack of emphasis around i think us
being
originators and creators of of what we
see on cable tv
i remember a few years ago kim
kardashian got conroes
or something like that and then
magazines and blogs were saying oh my
gosh the kim konros or the kim braids
and it's like black people have been
doing this for millennia not even
centuries millennia like
this is part of our culture and it's
just very disheartening
when you see someone else hijack your
culture and get the
um you know the accolades for it i can
tell the difference when someone
a cultural appropriation versus cultural
appreciation
these are two very different things and
when you are appreciating someone's
culture and i see that
i am on board that is amazing you know
you clearly you know what it means she's
done your homework
but when you're appropriating locks and
it's just candy-colored mess
and it's and then it's attacking and
it's that is
so the two are very different what is
appropriate way for someone to
show their appreciation you know when it
comes to celebs like iggy azalea and
kylie jenner
i started from the bottom and now i'm
rich i
got in my they're called out repeatedly
for cultural appropriation
is there an expectation for them to
acknowledge where their
their look originated from each and
every time they show it off on the
ground
is that what we're asking for or or what
is it
what do we expect from these people
i expect authenticity that's all nothing
more i expect
authenticity i expect you not to wear
culture as costume
um and i think and authenticity you know
we can
you authenticity is again it's something
you can't buy it's something you can't
fake
and when something is authentic people
feel that and people connect with that
but when you're wearing culture as a
costume um
a lot of times it's very obvious if you
don't even know the meaning behind some
of the the costume that you're wearing
that's very obvious so i think i don't
um i don't expect anything except
authenticity from people
then of course kylie jenner she's built
a billion dollar business
off of making your lips fuller
why does it hurt yeah i think that i do
understand in a sense why it hurts
it's like the experience i think of i
mean let's just take the common
experience of scrolling through your
instagram feed right
when you again start to see um
something regurgitated back to you or a
version of that in a way that feels less
tasteful or inauthentic right
going back to this idea of we can know
feel and see
um when something is being done solely
and specifically for profit and
attention
versus something that you are generally
into and think is amazing right
or have done research around or maybe an
influence of the different kinds of
people who you keep around you
and so i think what hurts is when number
one
um we know that it's not authentic
because we can see it
and also because i think this this sense
of of ownership that i think that we
have
around um protecting uh little pieces of
i think
our culture or what is representative of
us
it is so okay to be
and to feel um off or slighted or
to have a reaction around seeing it
because oftentimes i think as black
women we
have not been praised we have not been
given attention for
a lot of these traits or physical
characteristics that we are now seeing
but i think that there is um a
resilience that you kind of have to
develop by
um surrounding yourself around the
images and the people that you
do feel are authentic and a
representation
of you um i think that that's the way
that you can like personally combat it
um i always try to just go back to the
individual because i think it's really
important for us to remember that we are
all even as black women
multi-dimensional so different i mean
we've all kind of talked about our
different journeys with beauty
individually right but i think that i
have to
figure out what my power and what my
agency is so i can
create what the opposite of that is or
what i actually want to
see so that i can start to give that and
spread that around
to the girl whether she is 50 years old
or she's five who follow kim kardashian
i agree with you and i think two of the
things that make me upset as a black
woman when i see
the kim kardashians and kylie jenner's
get benefit
or or being you know heralded as the
leaders or the trendsetters
for things that we as black women have
had forever is like for example with the
um big lip implants um
as a black woman i remember feeling so
insecure about my lips when i was uh
younger like oh my god they're so big
but now people are literally injecting
and pain to have
lips like mine and so it's just
frustrating seeing women that are not
black
get praised for having black beaches
that we have been looked down upon for
so long
okay you're benefiting of black culture
but what are you doing for the black
culture
hair is fashion fashion is hair hair is
also a social statement
a political statement and a way to
own yourself if i'm to be honest before
probably two years ago i wouldn't have
felt comfortable wearing my hair
the way it is to work just to make sure
that i'm like
polished and clean that was that's what
i would tell myself
even though that was just the wrong idea
to have i think that we are such
in a place that we have been through
also this natural hair movement
again because of social media we are
you know seeing people create and do
things and start new trends
literally around their hair whether it
is on the runway or if it's on instagram
live
and i also think that um there's a sense
of rebellion here too for black women i
think that
for so long or what you kind of grew up
realizing is that
no matter how you wear your hair is
going to be politicized by the world
and so knowing that i feel like a lot of
black women are just kind of like
i'm just going to do whatever i want i'm
going to wear my hair to to the office
this way
i'm going to wear my hair in this
natural style and so i would describe it
as black women really
making um their own choices and really
going with their own instincts and again
doing what they want with their hair the
thing that upsets me too is especially
when it comes to hair
black women we've always been made to
feel like our hair is inferior you go
to work or you can't have braids or you
can't have locks it doesn't fit the
um the aesthetic of the workplace or
whatever whatever excuses they give
but then when it's done by someone else
who's not black
it's all of a sudden cool and acceptable
and i think that's where
the it's just unfair a lot of black
women
felt it's not even felt they had to
press their hair out because
of situation that's why we have the
crown act right certain people would get
fired because of their hair
being natural or wearing braids so it
was
a necessity it was more out of a
necessity not because we wanted to be
more
european straight hair is not exclusive
to white people that's not or that's not
a caucasian trait
you could be black and have naturally
state straight hair
um but my thing as well is black women
because before this i'm i've been going
out my hair for the last
or a year or so but before i used to get
a buzz cut
and it was just because i i liked it i
liked the look on me
and it was just annoying because
everyone thought it was a political
statement instead of me just
being okay with having a shaved head you
know it's always like oh are you like
sticking it to white supremacy is this
your way of you know
um going against it i'm like no i just
like my hair sure like not everything
that we do has to be politicized
that's why it's so important for us to
kind of feel and control a little bit of
our
not a little bit but a lot of our
individual images and the choices
that we make and knowing that like
whether people decide that i'm being
deep or not deep at all i'm just
cool with how i look and i think i look
amazing being inclusive
for me always came second nature i've
applied that to everything that i've
done
because i see how women become so
emotionally
invested and they feel represented they
feel like they can see
themselves on the shelves and the
campaigns sasha there has been some
visible progress made when it comes to
representation in the beauty industry
we've seen companies hire more diverse
models to really reflect what the world
looks like
a number of brands have expanded their
products to include more skin tones
and we see more black faces on magazine
covers
but what are some of the necessary
changes that you are still waiting to
see whether they're
solely in the beauty industry or in
society in general
i think the response to you know where
we're seeing black women included in a
lot of things
um a lot of it you know black women
spend and i've said this from blue in
the face
black women spend two to three times
more than their counterparts
on um beauty so it uh i don't want to
not pretend a lot of it
isn't a financial uh the number it isn't
numbers based
because you can't you're leaving money
on the table when you're excluding
black women i would like to see more
black women behind the scenes
involved more in the creation of some of
these things i want to see
more black creatives more uh black women
in product development
and when i say more i don't mean the one
because you know we're not all a model
if we don't it's not monolith that we
don't all
think the same we don't have the same
ideas i want to see different black
women with different perspectives and
product development
there has been a lot of change but i am
always
interested in seeing more change and
overall
you know i think that
you don't have to look very far to see
the change that you need as a brand
because the information is out there and
also you have a direct pipeline
to your customers you know you can uh
you know
again social media what what do you want
to see what is missing here i need
you know and brands are actually
responding to it you know your voice
does matter
so those are those are the changes that
i'm interested in seeing moving forward
it's just
more black women in general in front and
behind the scenes
as a user as a follower of so many of
these black creatives who i'm now
seeing and following online is what is
my responsibility a little bit as a as a
follower to
uplift where i can show support um
share add something to my instagram
story because
i think that i don't ever want to settle
or say this is just the way things are
things are never going to change i'm
never going to see people
who um who i think are talented get the
recognition that they deserve
but i think that also i'm trying to use
my agency and a little bit of like
my own taste and sensibilities to really
um in a little bit of my platform just
as a follower right
to say hey i recognize you and i see you
and um and i see all the hard work that
you're doing around your content
um i understand what you're trying to do
i know that you're
typing in these captions yourself like
you know what i mean i think i really
try to just have this real focus
in this admiration and this energy that
i think
sometimes i really hope um inspires i
think
creators and just people who um and
people who i talk to and report on you
know i think that sometimes
people will look at us and think that
we're that we're the cool ones but i
think i look at everyone else i me
and other and other people i meet and
i'm like you're cool you know and so i
think i really try to instill that a
little bit
and i and and also i think that i
am very much into this idea of like
creating things that aren't just for um
that aren't just in response to
whiteness that aren't in response to
white supremacy that isn't always in
response to racism
i think that that as like when i see
that from us
i think that that is in fact just a
natural form of resistance
i'm curious help us to set out who are
some of the brands that are created by
black women that you're currently using
or that you would recommend for us to
use
if each one of you want to tell us at
least one brand
at least one brand you know as a when
you're a makeup artist you kind of
know what you need and you know how to
tweak it a little bit so you know what's
amazing so a shinto sheriff who's an
amazing
makeup artist you know she has a couple
niche products
i also think naivasha johnson with curl
queen beauty she's introduced this
innovative new glove
that stimulates the scalp which is
beautiful and it's based on again it's
an artist that's in the field
that knows those holes that are missing
in the beauty market
um and it's also tracey ellis lost with
pattern beauty she's
my son uses powder you know she's
perfected that
and gabrielle union you know these are
women who have had their hair
with flawless by gu so these are women
who have gone through so much trial and
error
and they just knew where these holes
were in the market and they filled them
i think of course right now sharon
shooter she's the founder of oma beauty
and also the founder of the pull up for
change initiative that really
pushed brands specifically beauty brands
but then i would say
across industry to post um you know
the the diversity of their corporate
teams and
um has really just started to be a voice
and
i think that she has this experience
both from corporate and
in starting her own brand and i think
she brings a lot of sensibilities
to what she believes in in her message
and her interviews and when she speaks
with people
and then i would just say a brand right
now that i am
super excited i think about their
formula and the innovation and where
they might go
is black girl sunscreen and i just like
that formula a lot i'm really interested
to see how they expand
i just love their sunscreen and
sometimes
actually like we'll just use that as my
primer that's how much i love it
i just think it's a great formula i
think it's an amazing product
and i just think it deserves shine for
being great
period i would say i'm vanessa myricks
she's
a black makeup artist and she's got her
own line
her foundation is amazing it literally
feels like you're not wearing anything
at all and she has a whole wide range of
colors
and she just launched in sephora so i i
think yeah she's one of my favorite
um makeup artists and her brand is one
of my favorites in regards to beauty how
can we as women in general
support each other better no matter what
color background we come from
just to celebrate each other celebrate
each other you know
and i'm not talking about in some big
grand way
um in and i'm talking about in a way
that in a quiet way that takes
no effort it takes no energy just
you look amazing if they look amazing
you're beautiful
your hair i noticed you changed your
hair that looks great
that's a beautiful lip color you're
wearing those small things that we do to
uplift someone
makes such a big difference in their day
and um
you know you never know you know someone
they could be trying that for the first
time
do whatever you want do you know what i
mean there is no state there is no safe
space
they're going to politicize it anyway
they're going to do whatever
you want to do and you know you'll get
your support from your team
from your your tribe along the way i'm
sorry i have to
repeat the same answer because i think
it's really true both
the big and small compliments whether
they're in person or
it's a comment on instagram of maybe uh
somebody who you follow and you can tell
that they're being really vulnerable
in this photo or that they're maybe
sharing something that they don't
normally share you know
i think that it's really important or
the way that i like to do it
is when i see another black woman
working and i can just
she's maybe done something that i can
tell is was just like really strategic
and really good for her or a grow or
just growth in some way or
maybe she's been doing something for a
really long time and she really hit her
stride
i like to just tell other women when i
noticed that because i think
this term has been so overused but i
really do believe that it just feels
good to be seen
and i know it feels good when i feel
seen by
by other people and so um
let's not deny ourselves that and let's
not deny that amongst one another you
know let's show and we appreciate one
another
and to do it often i love that tash
last but not least what's your take how
can we as women support each other
better
i would say um no judgment because i do
feel as women we are
each other's biggest critics and for me
on a personal level
um when a woman compliments me in
comparison to a man it just i feel so
much better you know it's like wow like
sis you see me i see you
um so i really think just having that
support as a sisterhood as women
is super important and just not judging
other women because of their beauty
choices
or for doing what they what makes them
feel good i think if we just
stop the judgment and just you know
appreciate each other
i mean could this panel have gone any
better i just i feel like
you three we're the perfect
group and i appreciate you honestly for
being so open
raw and honest i hope that this helps
educate inspire brings confidence to
someone
at least someone i know it will that's
listening so i just want to say i
appreciate all three of you
tash darian tasha let's keep this
conversation going make sure to follow
them on social media
and for more stories celebrating black
beauty and style stick with the stream